hi guys scifi recapped here
before we start warning
spoilers ahead today i'm gonna explain a
2021 spanish thriller and crime movie
called the vault
the movie begins with a ship sinking off
the coast of spain in 1645 drowning all
the treasures it carried in september
2009 a group of private marine salvagers
led by walter morland are searching the
shipwreck for treasures
one of the crew james free dives into
the wreck to search for a particular
chest with the motosic parvis magna
inscribed on it
he successfully retrieves the chest and
goes back to the boat unfortunately
their boat is cornered by spanish
authorities at the court walter loses
possession of the treasures to the
spanish government as they were taken
from spanish waters
they are transferred to a secret heavily
guarded vault underneath the bank of
spain and madrid walter meets a british
representative margaret who tells him
that his search for the treasure is over
now that spain has it however he does
not seem satisfied a year later a bright
young student at the university of
cambridge tom is meeting various oil
company representatives who generously
offer him jobs with impressive salaries
and other perks due to his bright ideas
that solve the gulf oil crisis however
he does not seem even slightly
interested in those offerings
while having dinner with his dad he
receives a mysterious text message
telling him to go outside to be offered
an interesting opportunity he proceeds
with the instruction until he meets a
short-haired blonde woman claudia who
leads him to meet walter in a bar
walter calls her by her real name
lorraine
he then expresses his intention to
recruit tom to break into an
impenetrable bank vault he is convinced
tom is the right person to do the job
because as an engineer he can construct
the problem about the vault and offer a
solution
he gives tom his airline ticket to
madrid allowing him to think through it
tom agrees to accept the job and boards
the plane to madrid
at the airport he meets lorraine this
time with a different appearance the
whole country is celebrating the 2010
world cup season with people flocking
into the streets to watch the games tom
meets walter's other team members simon
james and klaus
he impresses them by giving an idea to
trick a bank employee to give his
voicemail code so klaus can access the
bank security system
in the evening walter explains that he
has been searching for the treasure for
30 years which makes it very important
to him it originally belonged to sir
francis drake stolen from the spanish
but he kept it for his own instead of
delivering it to the british crown the
most prized treasure would be the chest
with sick parvis magna which hosts three
coins containing coordinates to more
treasure
back in the group's base they explained
to tom that they have been mapping the
underground tunnels near the bank as
they intend to enter the vault from
below
they realize unlocking the vault would
need two keys in the fingerprint of
gustavo medina the bank's head of
security
first they need to scan the structure of
the vault using a magnetometer to map it
tom volunteers to do it as he knows how
to use the device
he disguises himself as a cleaning
service along with simon while lorraine
disguises herself as an art curator who
comes to the bank to inspect its
artworks
she actually wants to scan the vault's
keys placed in safes during her time in
the chairman's office she notices an
unlocked window deducing that the
chairman has been smoking in his office
tom uses the magnetometer under the
table in a meeting room but an error
occurs causing him to start over the
device which triggers the bank's fire
alarm
gustavo and the team proceed with the
security protocol but could not locate
the trigger of the alarm assuming it is
just a power outage
examining the magnetometer scan results
tom deduces that the vault sits beneath
a large water tank and it acts like a
giant weighing scale
if there is a change in weight inside
the vault a mechanism will trigger water
from the tank to flood the vault
trapping and drowning the thieves inside
meanwhile gustavo is scolded as the
earlier fire alarm causes soldiers to
flock into the bank and scare the world
cup supporters who are crowding the
streets and square in front of it
james and simon locate the base of the
vault through the underground tunnels
proving tom's theory that it is a giant
scale
however the wall consists of titanium
reinforced concrete which takes 15 days
to drill longer than the time they have
the team gives up but walter observing
the security cameras placed around the
bank all point to the crowd gathering in
sibel square to watch the world cup
deduces that they can break in from
above during the football games by
selecting a spot not exposed to the
cameras
the best time to do it will be during
the grand final match
meanwhile the actual bank's cleaning
service tells the security men that he
has not gone to work for two days making
them wonder who were the cleaners
yesterday
they quickly realized the cleaners used
fake identities but due to tom and simon
not having any criminal records their
true identities are not discovered the
team panics but walter tells tom to
focus on solving the scale problem while
he makes a call to margaret a member of
the british intelligence service mi6
he tells her to pass false information
that two men matching the appearance of
simon and tom were arrested at london
heathrow airport to reduce gustavo's
suspicion of the planned heist the
bank's chairman is convinced the heist
problem has been solved and allows the
crowd to gather in sebel square for the
anticipated final match between spain
and netherlands
lorraine asks tom for a drink at a local
bar where they can unwind
he observes the barista making cold
drinks by spraying nitrogen and gets an
idea
he demonstrates to the team that by
freezing the scale using nitrogen it
will not register the weight change
from that they work on a plan
simon will have to get 500 liters of
cold nitrogen to freeze a scale as big
as the vault tom lorraine and james will
enter the bank and klaus and walter will
monitor them the night before the heist
they drink rum and voice their regrets
although none of them expresses any
regret for joining the mission on the
d-day tom james and lorraine enter the
bank's main foyer by cutting through a
glass panel in the roof
by class guidance they are able to time
their departure to not be seen by the
patrolling guards
they enter a room without a security
camera and access the air vents tom not
used to physical activities slows down
the team but he still manages to stick
through the plan
although they are 10 minutes late from
the schedule they finally arrive at the
vault
simon then begins to freeze the scales
it takes a long time for the vault to
freeze almost making james give up on
the mission
however tom is sure his way will work
and they can safely enter the vault he
takes a confident first step and the
scale remains balanced allowing them to
search the room lorraine discovers the
chest and the coins
meanwhile the bank security discovers
that there has been a hole in the roof
used earlier by tom and his friends to
enter the building
gustavo orders his men to search the
entire building and block all exits back
in the vault the effect of the nitrogen
wears off causing the scales to detect
the weight change and triggering the
water to flood the room
james who actually has an agenda on his
own to retrieve the treasure back to the
british crown threatens lorraine to give
him the coins then leave by swimming
through the tank
tom and lorraine unable to match his
swimming ability are left in the vault
gasping for air before the vault is
completely flooded during those moments
walter is already prepared to call the
bank and turns himself in so that the
water can be stopped but tom says it is
no use as the water would not stop
flowing until the vault is completely
flooded
he then wonders how would the vault
detect whether the water is full
he suggests that the weight of the
flooded vault will register on the
scales and trigger the water to stop
flowing
he asks simon who is listening to the
final world cup match on his dad's old
radio to trick the scales by placing
empty nitrogen can so the scales will
detect heavier weights
however the water does not seem to stop
flowing making klaus and walter believe
they have lost tom and lorraine
the water then stops after simon places
his dad's old radio on the scales
the vault drains all its flooded water
then gustavo and his men enter the vault
to find nobody
he deduces the thieves might have
escaped through the vents and orders the
guards to search the building out of
options to escape lorraine thinks of the
unclosed window at the chairman's office
she heads there with tom successfully
escaping to the crowds of football
supporters on the streets where gustavo
will not be able to shoot at them
they try to lose themselves but police
are coming at them from almost every
direction so they decide to stop running
and share a kiss
at the same time spain scores in the
final causing the crowd to erupt into
happiness
the celebration allows them to escape
and make their way safely back to walter
in the british embassy james shows the
coins he obtained to margaret
after deciphering them they realize that
the coordinates lead to the eiffel tower
a place margaret has mentioned to walter
the coins were actually swapped by
lorraine so james took the fake ones
while the originals are safe in walters
hands
when asked by tom walter answers that he
suspects james might betray him so he
prepared the fake coins
they then decipher the coordinates on
the real coins sometime later a month
before the london 2012 olympics lorraine
with a new identity and appearance is
seen entering the bank of england
possibly preparing another heist
subscribe to watch more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for
watching